[Music]
spiral from the book of saw may have new
characters
new lore and a new killer but it's still
a saw movie
right through its big twist ending
here's everything you need
explained about the twisted ending of
the ninth saw movie
spiral from the book of saw the biggest
reveal at the end of spiral is
also the most obvious the identity of
the serial killer who's been hunting
down the members of the south metro
police precinct
as savvy viewers probably guessed the
killer is none other than zeke's new
partner
william shank played by max mingela
as he lays out in a scooby-doo-esque
monologue at the end of the film
shank is the son of the witness who
zeke's former partner
pete dunleavy killed in order to protect
a dirty cop
ever since that fateful night shink
which isn't his real name by the way
has been planning his revenge and he
wants zeke's help
as zeke proved by turning in pete and
ruining both of their careers
he's one of the few honest cops in a
precinct that's rife with corruption
by targeting dirty cops and forcing them
to make amends for their misdeeds
usually by sacrificing one of their body
parts shink
hopes to scare the other officers into
going straight
if not well he'll be there to punish
them
while shink thinks zeke is the ideal
partner for his depraved
scheme the veteran detective disagrees
so
of course shink has created a trap that
forces zeke to make a near impossible
choice
zeke can use the single bullet left in
his gun to shoot a target that stops his
captured father from bleeding out
or he can shoot chiang zeek chooses to
save his dad
but as shank gets away a swat team
bursts into the room
thanks to shanks trap they mistakenly
see the elder banks
as a gun wielding threat and kill him
anyway
during his big reveal shank lays out
exactly how he manipulated zeke
and managed to escape detection for so
long he lured zeke's father
marcus to an abandoned location by
borrowing zeke's phone
he faked his own death by copying his
tattoo onto a corpse
he pretended to have a wife and an
infant son in order to divert zeke's
suspicion
he even dropped little hints during the
investigation
shink notes near the beginning your dad
is the reason for all of this
he is why i want to do this in the first
place a comment which can be interpreted
in different ways
whether you think shank is a rookie cop
or the ruthless killer
at the time zeke is left none the wiser
there are other clues though which
spiral doesn't explicitly lay out
shanks tattoo says charlie which he
passes off as the name of his fictional
son
but which is also the first name of the
man dun levy murdered
what are you doing oh it's uh family
this is my wife
emma's my son charlie cute
in a movie like this that's not a
coincidence the killer also wears a pig
mask given that pig is a derogatory term
for a cop
zeke maybe should have started looking
for suspects inside the precinct a
little earlier
finally the killer targets police
officers with skeletons in their closets
and reveals their sins via videotape
when zeke
visits the scene of shanks supposed
murder however
the audio track fades out before we can
hear what the tape has to say about the
young detective's past
hinting that it's not important or as it
turns out is completely fictional
even if shanks interpretation of john
kramer's philosophy is muddled
the final scene in spiral is saw through
and through
for most of its run time spiral has its
own tone the traps are shot and edited
like the death scenes and saw and its
sequels
but the rest of the film is closer to a
police procedural or dark crime drama
than the torture porn vibe that defines
saw and its imitators in the end though
spiral finally becomes
a saw movie typically soften alleys
share a number of the same elements
there's always some big twist or reveal
like the dead body and saw not being
dead at all
or the unmasking of one of john kramer's
many accomplices
the most emotionally resonant death is
usually saved for the end
the hero finds a new low sometimes while
facing down his or her
eminent demise while the bad guy gets
away
the big climax of spiral has all of
those
william shank raising a finger to his
lips as the elevator door closes
and he escapes to safety the revelation
that zeke's father marcus isn't actually
safe at all
as the machine that he's strapped to
lifts him into the air and begins
raising his arm
pointing a rifle at the door marcus's
death as the swat team bursts into the
room
and a close-up on chris rock's tortured
face
you can even hear hello zepp the saw
franchise's ominous theme song
playing just before the credits roll for
most of its run time
spiral shies away from the saw formula
only to embrace it at the very end
for long time fans it should work very
very well
the saw franchise likes to play fast and
loose with its timeline which also leads
to some of the series biggest reveals
the twist at the end of saw four for
example is that the prologue
in which detective hoffman examines john
cramer's body
actually takes place after the rest of
the movie it's a flash forward
which completely changes its
significance in the story
jigsaw makes viewers think john cramer
has miraculously survived death
only to reveal that his scenes took
place years earlier
spyro plays similar tricks fairly early
in spiral marcus banks goes missing
he won't return phone calls and he's not
at his apartment when zeke stops by
that's why it's a little surprising when
he suddenly shows up two-thirds of the
way through
investigating an old soap factory right
after zeke is captured
as the end of the movie reveals this is
a fake out
the scene depicting marcus's capture
actually comes
some time between the time that shank
borrows zeke's phone
and zeke's first visit to marcus's
apartment right around the time that
fitch dies
in terms of setting up a fair mystery
yeah it's kind of cheating
but mr x like that are also time-honored
saw traditions
you're just gonna have to roll with it
the saw franchise has gotten political
before
saw six kicks off with a trap punishing
two subprime mortgage lenders remember
this was 2009
before jumping into a story about the
inequalities of the for-profit medical
insurance industry
as far as political satire goes it's
pretty clunky but it's there
the devices on your heads are symbolic
of the shackles that you place upon
others
similarly spiral flirts with social
commentary too
the entire story hinges on police
corruption
particularly police brutality zeke is
ostracized because he tattles on an
officer who killed a witness in order to
cover up a different event
in which an officer threw someone off of
a rooftop
fitch is killed because he shot a
suspect who talked back to him
marcus and his successor angie are
marked for death as the masterminds
behind
article 8 a police policy that lowered
crime rates at the cost
of civilians lives the real world
parallels and spiral
are impossible to ignore but spyral
never fully commits to its anti-police
brutality message
[ __ ] condemns the entire policing
system but then clarifies that he's only
targeting bad cops
implying that plenty of them are okay
which makes for a muddled message
and motive for a psychopathic villain
the main lesson in spiral seems to be
that there's no way to be a good police
officer
either you're corrupt and violent or you
end up like zeke
who's despised by his peers and loses
everything he has
there's something interesting there it's
too bad that the movie doesn't go all
the way with its moral stance
we already know we're getting another
saw movie saw x was greenlit
well before spyral debuted and while
chris rock notes that a direct
spiral sequel depends on how this one
does at the box office
he's ready to return if asked with that
in mind it's pretty easy to see what a
sequel might explore as the credits roll
william shank is free to cause more
mayhem while zeke knows his identity
it's clear that his mission to violently
reform the police still has a long way
to go
jigsaw's legacy still looms over the
city too after all
shank is the second jigsaw copycat to
cause havoc
chances are there's going to be a third
that's not even counting all of jigsaw's
accomplices
including lawrence gordon who as of the
end of saw 3d
the final chapter is still at large if
the studio wants to pay carrie elwis to
return and face off against chris rock
he wouldn't turn that down it's possible
that there are other jigsaw proteges
lurking out there too
he does have a bunch of them as far as
zeke's personal arc is concerned
there's plenty to mind there too his
soon-to-be ex-wife
only had one scene in spiral but could
play a bigger part in future
installments
after all saw movies loved a toy with
the hero's loved ones
he didn't hit rock bottom until the very
end of spiral so
seeing how someone comes back from a
loss like that could be very compelling
as a franchise saw is famous for playing
the long game
when it comes to the world of spiral
we're probably just getting started
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spiral
and the soft franchise are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you